[Music]
before you see the whimsical new
animated feature hey before you see the
whimsical nip hey before you see the
whimsical new Empire
you know what the epiglottis isn't the
right fit for Wes Anderson get anyone
here do a good Alec Baldwin hello
close enough take it away Baldy before
you see the whimsical new animated
feature from your baristas favorite
director revisit all his meticulously
crafted awkward family fables that make
you kinda happy kinda sad and kinda
unsure when you're supposed to laugh or
not
[Music]
why are they laughing every Wes Anderson
movie
I mean film every Wes Anderson film
sally forth and Tallyho with director
Wes Anderson whose style is so specific
he's basically his own genre featuring
more symmetrical shots than you can
shake an art department at more
nostalgia than you can cram into a
quirky indoor tent and more whimsy than
a lovestruck Cub Scout dancing in his
underwear to a lakeside record player
honestly after eight movies I'm not sure
if I made that shot up or not oh there
it is meet a Wes Anderson protagonist
he's definitely not a woman but an
emotionally stunted man suffering from a
vague bout of on Yui how was that
supposed to make us feel watch him deal
with a strained parental relationship
your mother's asked me to leave why
didn't you come a dead sooner because I
didn't want to sibling rivalries and
maybe an affair you've made a cuckold of
me I think he's on to us of course he is
but with the help of a brown subordinate
slash love interest a Wardrobe full of
dapper menswear and a classic
slow-motion walk he'll end up happy I
think it's sort of hard to tell but
that's what makes it artistic Rivas in
eight films as meticulously crafted as
the dollhouse sets they probably feature
including a tale of two disaffected
friends the cleaning woman that one of
them loves and a meticulously planned
robbery that goes wrong a tale of this
disaffected student his disaffected
older friend the teacher both of them
love and a meticulously planned revenge
plot that goes wrong a tale of this
disaffected family the sister that one
of them loves and a meticulously planned
family reunion that goes wrong a tale of
this disaffected oceanographer the
reporter both he and his son love and a
meticulously planned documentary that
goes wrong
a tale of these disaffected brothers the
trains do it as one of them loves and a
meticulously planned trip through India
the
wrong a tale of his disaffected Fox the
wife he loves and a meticulously planned
different robbery that goes wrong
a tale of these disaffected kids who are
in love with each other and the
meticulously planned escape that goes
wrong and the tale of this hotel manager
the dead old one he loves and the
meticulously planned paradise that goes
wrong it sounds repetitive but trust me
they're just the most charming little
things so before you see the adorable
looking Isle of Dogs revisit the
director who can only be described as
Wes Anderson who's influenced an entire
generation of indie filmmakers and an
even larger generation of pale hipsters
who hate their parents you just don't
get me dad I was born in the wrong
decade starring overhead shots of
objects stage plays funerals facial
wounds zooms
[Music]
shots of writing shots of typewritten
letters with pans
[Music]
characters explaining elaborate plans
escape route just in case someone is
tailing us we'll start with Boggess
chicken house number one it's 25 inches
of reinforced granite masonry I like to
pitch camp here about 1,600 characters
running away suddenly
[Music]
the future of font whimsical names Klaus
Daimler Bob ample for every apple
rosemary cross Applejack
did I miss a little gene face punches
you tried five characters with dead
parents my mother's dead lambs Baron's
passed away a number of years ago you
should have been a dancer no my father
died at seven-and-a-half my father was
murdered Willem Dafoe dead animals
Willem Dafoe playing a dead animal
anjelica huston
old timey telephones anjelica huston
on an old timey telephone foreigners
classic rock songs
[Music]
oil paintings a foreigner playing a
classic rock song in front of an oil
painting characters reading books
uniforms graveyards a character reading
a book wearing a uniform in a graveyard
Jason Schwartzman smoking moving
vehicles Jason Schwartzman smoking
outside a moving vehicle a Wilson
brother strange sibling relationships
exotic animals a Wilson brother and his
estranged sibling smoking with an exotic
animal ed norton reel-to-reel tape
recorders and norton dictating into a
reel-to-reel tape recorder while smoking
and wearing a uniform
Bill Murray tiny motorcycles profile
shots and Bill Murray on a tiny
motorcycle in a profile shot every Wes
Anderson movie you know we gave him crap
for repeating himself but the last thing
anyone wants is a desaturated shaky-cam
CGI fest out of him just a movie about
the drama club at Hogwarts hey Internet
do you love puppies then click the link
on the left because we got the cast of
Pacific Rim to play with puppies we
present Pacific Rim uprising where there
is life there is hope
oh we're using our made-up names than I
am spider-man remind me why do I keep
raiding all these white eared comments